what we're hoping is that the by
understanding the genetic basis of the
disease that we begin to understand the
fundamental biology understanding the
disease so by exploring and
understanding which genes might
contribute to the development of
schizophrenia for example what we are
interested in finding is does this tell
us anything about the biology and the
pathways underline that and as a result
of that we may be able to find a target
so we may be able to find a maybe a
receptor or some kind of a protein that
we would be able to target with some
kind of pharmacology and then we're
hoping that because that has targeted
targeted us in on the fundamental basis
of the disease and that we've developed
some pharmacology against that
underlying basis of disease that our
drugs are more likely to be more
effective in patients with those
diseases it also may translate we hope
in the future and to be able to
targeting specific treatments towards
specific patient groups so-called
personalized medicine so helping to
understand that action fact by doing
this we may be able to find specific
patient groups who are going to respond
even particularly well to the drugs that
we develop
the concept of personalized medicine
ideally would be the right drug in the
right dose at the right time for the
right patient so in other words a
patient comes in to a doctor and a
doctor is able to do some kind of
specific screen is able to identify the
components that contribute to that
person's disease be it environmental
biet genetic or be another kind of
biological parameter in an ideal world
that would translate into one sort of
simple diagnostic that a doctor would be
able to do on the spot so-called point
of care diagnostics and by doing that a
doctor would be able to say for you with
this disorder this is the right
treatment for you you're really going to
respond to this this treatment and
you're not going to have any side
effects that's the ideal scenario that's
quite a long way off what we are doing
those were making a lot of progress in
beginning to understand particularly in
areas like oncology on cancer treatments
which of the characteristics for example
of the tumors that would make them more
susceptible to particular treatment so
we're now able to be better a targeting
or and many of our treatments in the
cancer arena to patients based on the
makeup of the tumors which we've
identified via genetic or genomic
signature and we can say you're more
likely to respond to this drug you're
less likely to have side effects and so
on and in an ideal world as we move out
into the future maybe everybody will
have their whole genome sequence so when
they come into the doctor the doctor can
read out their genome sequence and be
able to sort of say I can identify that
drug for you and be able to prescribe
the right drug for them
for the individual at the moment our
ability to translate that genetic
information at the moment into
individual risk prediction for in other
words to say that you will get a
particular disease based on this variant
is still very limited at the moment so
the technology is significantly advanced
you can do these you can provide these
genome snips the technology for
sequencing is rapidly advancing I think
their estimates up now that the cost of
sequencing of fully human genome can be
done for somewhere between maybe five
and ten thousand dollars or something
like that at the moment that cost is
going to come down and come down but at
some stage in the future we probably
will be able to crunch to a large degree
the meaning of this information and and
relate that back to an individual's risk
of disease or risk of progression of
disease but we're still quite a bit of a
bit of away from that and that's kind of
where the that's where a lot of the
debate is with for example with the
personal genomics companies which is yes
you can do this sequencing and provide
this information but how useful is that
information at the moment because how
many fill is that to the individuals so
we've probably got a bit of a way to go
with that
the most interesting thing I think about
the genetics and this is particularly in
a sort of three or four years is that
the technologies have allowed us to look
at jeans potentially contributing to
disease or contributing the risk of the
disease in a what we call a hypothesis
freeway in other words we don't know
what we're looking for we've got the
technology and we're looking without any
a priori a decision about what of what
it is that my piensan and what we're
doing as a result of that is we're
picking out things we would never have
thought of so we're finding genes that
we would never have considered it now we
don't necessarily understand that at the
moment but what that's doing and helping
us with us it's taking us into new areas
of biology so it's allowing us to unto
explore and understand biology that we
would never have thought about before so
I think that that's the one area that I
would say this is where genetics kind of
changes the paradigm of how we look at
biology where's in the past we would
have said and this is our our favorite
candidate for based on our knowledge of
the biology which we admit is imperfect
let's look at this gene and see whether
this gene is involved and that's a very
labor-intensive and it's often not been
a very successful approach but the
hypothesis freeway of being able to use
these massive and throughput
technologies has uncovered lots of
interesting biology that we haven't
thought about before and I think that's
one of the that's one of the big
learnings
now an actual fact we haven't discovered
a huge amount about obesity genes at the
moment but you know they're almost
certainly years and we know that there
are genes involved in the development of
predisposition to diabetes and so on and
we know that diabetes is going to become
a massive problem over the next set of
20 to 30 years ago estimates in the
range of 400 million people with
diabetes by 2030 around the world and
what were what we would like to
understand is how does your genetic
predisposition interact with your
environmental predisposition to you know
culture what what kind of foods that you
eat you know etc etc and that's the
piece that we want to try and you know
understand and sort of tease apart and
what for diabetics what does that mean
in terms of your likelihood of getting
cardiovascular disease and so on so I
think those are the areas in which is
going to be a lot of work to try and
sort of understand the differences in
populations and the differences in rates
of obesity between different populations
how much of that is genetic how much of
it is environment and what can one do
together to get around the other so what
kind of lifestyle changes can you make
to get around your genetic
predisposition to get developing obesity
and and also what kind of behavioral
components might make it difficult or
easy for you to do that you know because
it's often very difficult for people to
change their lifestyle and that's where
that's where it's often the big
challenge so we all know what we're
supposed to do in order to keep healthy
most of the time but it's difficult to
do
the way that I think about it is that as
we as we develop new drugs I feel that I
well I believe that personalized
medicine is the defining paradigm for
how we're going to do discovery and
development of drugs over there over the
next few years when when we think about
truly personalized medicine actually all
of these things have to come together so
we have to have so the biology has to
take us in the right direction of which
drugs that we which pharmacology we
develop that's going to have to
translate into the populations in which
we research and develop those drugs and
when we go out into the marketplace and
we've got drugs that are going to be
used in populations it's not going to
work on this we have electronic medical
records the ability to you know personal
health records portable personal health
records is is my belief as well as the
whole integration of a practice in a
healthcare setup that's geared towards
treating the the individual with with
his or heart disease so all of these
things have to come together and it's
quite a lot we've got quite a long way
to go in order to do that we've got to
build that kind of infrastructure that
enables us to do that as well as
exploiting the biology that's beginning
to emerge but it's going to take a lot
it's going to take a long long time for
that to do that to get to that kind of
ideal vision where somebody comes into
the doctor's office maybe he or she has
a little access card which contains all
of his or her medical records the doctor
can access all of the medical records
without a patient ever having to sit
down and fill out a form that maybe that
individuals complete genomic sequences
already because maybe the whole genomic
sequence has been had been done at birth
because it's so cheap and a patient
carries that around with him hard for
forever and the doctor is able to go in
and is he's able to look at the medical
records he's been he's able to integrate
in a very complex way
II with a very simple out part the
various different factors that go into
sort of describing and diagnosing what
this patient has and then coming out
with a pretty clear and well described
treatment regimes for that individual
patient be that and depending on
whatever and whatever it is that that
patient has and knowing that that the
the drug if it's a drug that's going to
be given to that patient is much more
likely to be effective and much less
likely to cause problems
what I do is the group that I am
responsible for advisor and is a group
that really exploits the science and the
technologies that underpin the
development of personalized medicine I
think one of the critical challenges
over the next few years is to be able to
bring these technologies and the
information that they bring from very
different kinds of domains and to be
able to do kind of complex and
multi-dimensional and analysis in order
to be able to make the most use of the
information be that environmental
information genomic information genetic
information information from imaging and
so on and to be able to distill that
down into a good understanding of the
disease that we can then take clearly
into the challenges that we have in
running clinical trials so a big big
challenge that we have in running
clinical trials is that many of the
clinical trials that we have to do at an
early stage in in in development are
going to be they're going to be long and
they're going to be very expensive we've
got to figure out a way to do those
clinical trials cheaper quicker so that
we can afford to develop the dogs to
bring those to market and there's a
number of areas in which those are going
to be very challenging and Alzheimer's
disease diabetes and cardiovascular risk
and those are going to be areas that are
going to be very challenging I guess the
two disease areas in particular that I'd
love to see em and you know really
succeed at and are you know the
development of treatments for
Alzheimer's disease obviously I've got
I've had some Alzheimer's disease that's
in the family and it would be great if
we could solve a lot of the challenges
about really treating the disease
underlying Alzheimer's and schizophrenia
which i think is just a you know a
horrendous the a.m crippling and
disabling disorder which we don't fully
understand and which I saw a lot of it
during my years in clinical practice I'd
love to see us really get to grips with
sort of
defeating and you know really developing
great treatments for schizophrenia
when I look at the group of people that
I have working in in Pfizer is a group
of very highly talented highly skilled
scientists within my group and I think
the the challenge that I feel in a sense
most proud of is having been able to
build that group into into I would say
pretty close to an intellectual power
house that's recognized within the
organization so that's that's the one
kind of challenge that I feel most proud
of I've been involved in a number of
sort of projects over the years that
have been fairly significant challenges
a number of years ago we put together a
team to build our own internal biobank
to store and how samples from clinical
trials that was a major achievement in
many ways because we developed a plan
and put a plan together to build the
first high-throughput robotic system at
minus 80 degrees to house a very large
collection of samples that will be used
and for which we've got great value out
of the research in over the next few
years or so but I was you know a big
team effort that we put together and I
was very proud of the work that we
achieved in that
I think what you'd what the next thing
you need to do is you need to have
people that have you know fundamentally
very strong scientific credibility and
that means that they've done very good
work and they've also got the ability to
talk about that work and in a convincing
way that other people at a very at the
same scientific peer level in an
organization can really get to
understand and believe yes they can
really do that and then you have to be
able to deliver on you know strong
scientific projects that you run and be
able to sort of say that when we do
something that we will deliver against
that will do very good science the
results may not always come out the way
that we want them to do but you know the
science that we do and delivers of the
top quality so what you really want to
do is you know focus on trying to get
those core group of people within those
individual scientists and who can then
lead the organization I'm a great
believer in in trying to recruit some of
the very top people and and letting them
do their thing and and that's you know
if you get the right people instead of
you know you don't necessarily you need
a huge number of them you just need the
right people to sort of and let them go
and do the thing because and most of the
people are so highly motivated that they
just they just get on with it and do it
and I think that's the secret to try to
create that kind of a group that will
you know work and work very well and
deliver lots of exciting stuff I one of
the things that always amazes me and I'm
always really thrilled by is actually
the excitement that people in the group
have around the work that they're doing
they're very excited by the science are
very excited by the challenges that they
face every day and you know they they
just come in and they love they love
doing that work and that's that's really
rewarding